how are we supposed to think about those
extra dimensions are we supposed to
imagine actual physical reality or
is this more in the space of mathematics
that allows you to
sort of come up with tricks to describe
the four-dimensional reality that we
more directly perceive
no one really knows the answer of course
but if i take the most straightforward
approach to string theory you really are
imagining that these dimensions
are there they're real i mean just as
you would
say that the three space dimensions
around us you know left right back forth
up down
yeah we they're real they're here we are
immersed within those dimensions
these other dimensions
are as real as these with the one
difference being their shape and their
size
differs from the shape and size of the
dimensions that we have direct access to
through through human experience
and one approach imagines that these
extra dimensions are tightly coiled up
curled up crushed together if you will
into a beautiful geometrical form
that's all around us but just too small
for us to detect with our eyes too small
for us to detect even with the most
powerful equipment that we have
nevertheless according to the
mathematics the size and the shape of
those extra dimensions leaves an imprint
in the world that we do have access to
so one of the ways that we have hoped
yet to achieve to make contact with
experimental physics
is to see a signature of those extra
dimensions in places like the large
hadron collider in geneva switzerland
and it hasn't happened yet doesn't mean
it won't happen
but that would be
a stunning moment in the history of the
species if data that we acquired in
these dimensions
gives us kind of incontrovertible
evidence
that these dimensions are not the only
dimensions i mean how mind-blowing
would would that be so with a large
header and collider it would be
something in the movement of the
particles or
also the gravitational waves potentially
be a place where you can detect signs of
multiple dimensions like with something
called ligo but much more accurate in
principle all of these can work so one
of the experiments that we had high
hopes for but by high hopes i'm actually
exaggerating one of the experiments that
we
imagined
might in the best of all circumstances
yield some insight we weren't with
baited breath waiting for the result we
knew it was a long shot when you slam
protons together at very high speed of
the large hadron collider if there are
these extra dimensions and if they have
the right
form and that's a hypothesis that may
not be correct but when the proteins
collide they can create debris energetic
debris that can in some sense leave our
dimensions and insert itself into the
other dimensions and the way you'd
recognize that is
there'd be more energy before the
collision than after the collision
because the debris would have taken
energy away from the place where our
detectors can detect it so that's that's
one real concrete way that you could
find evidence for extra dimensions but
yeah since extra dimensions are of space
and gravity is something that
exists within in fact is associated with
the shape of space gravitational waves
in principle can provide a kind of you
know cat scan of of the extra dimensions
if you had sufficient control over
those processes we don't yet but perhaps
one day we will
you